hemos hablado bastante sobre
transformaciones lineales y en este
vídeo y también en los siguientes
yo quiero mostrarte cómo esencialmente
diseñar una transformación lineal para
que haga con los vectores lo que tú
quieres que haga con ellos entonces ya
sabemos que una transformación lineal
digamos t que va de rn a rm entonces
podemos representar a teo o lo que lo
que te hace a algún vector lo podemos
representar como una matriz una matriz
que multiplica a un vector x esto sería
multiplicando al vector x y esto nos da
una matriz de m por n de m por n ahora
sabemos que siempre podemos construir
esta matriz que cualquier transformación
lineal puede ser representada como una
matriz de esta manera y la podemos
representar así tomando a nuestra matriz
identidad entonces lo que voy a hacer de
chinos ya lo has visto antes
esta matriz identidad con una filas y n
columnas donde se mira así
un uno aquí después en un 0 2 después 0
1 y todos los demás son ceros como
puedes ver solo tiene unos en la
diagonal principal es una matriz de n
por n entonces tomas la matriz identidad
y le aplicas la transformación lineal a
cada columna ajá entonces estas son las
columnas de la matriz identidad y las
las llamamos la base estándar de rn ésta
es la columna 1 esta es la 2 y como
tienen columnas esta es la n ahora cada
una de estas columnas es un miembro de
rn tienen elementos y sabemos que puede
ser representada como la transformación
que está siendo aplicada a cada columna
entonces a es igual a la transformación
aplicada a la primera columna hay 1
después la transformación aplicada a 2
hasta llegar a la transformación
aplicada
n y esto es algo que sirve mucho saber
porque porque es muy fácil aplicar la
transformación lineal a cada uno de
estos vectores que pertenecen a la base
estándar cierto solamente tienen un solo
uno y todo lo demás es cero entonces son
muy muy amigables y estos vectores
unitarios ahora como tú puedes ver esto
es un repaso entonces vamos a usar esto
para para construir una transformación
lineal interesante así que manos a la
obra vamos a iniciar con un conjunto en
rn y de hecho ya a todo todo lo que voy
a hacer es nn r2 solo para no complicar
tanto la vida pero tú lo puedes extender
a cualquier dimensión que quieras solo
que lo voy a hacer yo en r2 para la
simplicidad supongo digamos que tengo yo
un triángulo entonces tengo un triángulo
formado por los siguientes tres puntos
digamos que el punto este punto es el 3
2 el 3 2 ahora también el otro punto
sería que te parece
y menos 32 ok este punto es menos 32 o
bueno lo estoy haciendo en forma de
efecto al columna de hecho aquí puse a 3
sobre 2 no es una fracción me equivoqué
lo siento es menos 32 y 32 son los
vectores columna entonces ahí está ese
punto o ese vector y ahora sólo por
diversión uno por acá por abajo que te
parece el vector 32 entonces no tres
menos dos perdón tres
-2 ahí está ahora bien entonces ese
punto está más o menos por aquí ya
tenemos los tres puntos cada uno de
estos puntos son vectores yo puedo
dibujarlo saliendo del origen a cada uno
de estos puntos son vectores entonces
muy bien más que más que importarme que
sean vectores lo que me importa es la
posición que especifican y sabemos que
si tomamos al conjunto de todas las de
todos los vectores que forman este
triángulo sería en el conjunto que
conectan a estos tres puntos cierto ok
ahora a ese conjunto que conectan a
estos tres vectores o lo que sería el
triángulo mismo le vamos a aplicar la
transformación lineal a cada uno
entonces le aplicamos la transformación
lineal t a estos puntos y los conectamos
en el mismo orden de hecho ya lo hemos
visto eso antes pero ahora queremos
diseñar una transformación lineal
entonces ok perfecto digamos que
queremos de hecho de hecho lo que voy a
hacer es escribir lo que queremos hacer
voy a escribirlo lo que queremos hacer
primero que todo es
reflejarlo sobre el eje de las x
entonces queremos reflejarlo sobre el
eje de las equis o no mejor no mejor en
el egezy ok reflejarlo sobre el eje de
las 'íes' así que queremos voltear los
queremos voltearlo y una vez que lo
volvemos se va a mirar algo así cierto
algo así se va a mirar y también digamos
que queremos alargarlo por un por un 2
entonces queremos reflejarlo sobre el
eje de la sien y también queremos
alargarlo en la dirección en la
dirección y por 2 así que vamos a
primero voltearlo se va a mirar algo así
esto sería como el el paso 1 cierto el
paso uno es voltearlo esto es paso 1 y
el paso 2 es alargarlo se mirará en
lugar de así se va a mirar como tendrá
como el doble de altura ahora el la x se
va a quedar igual y ok como hacemos eso
la primera idea que tenemos es reflejar
sobre el eje de las yes entonces creemos
que
este punto este punto el menos 3 el
menos 3 está aquí
ajá el menos 32 que esa coordenada que
desde el otro lado con un 3 positivo
este 2 aquí es la coordenada jr este es
el eje de las yes ok entonces tenemos
menos 32 queremos que que esté menos 3
se convierta en un 3 positivo
queremos que quede que terminen en este
otro punto correspondiente cuando cuando
le demos la vuelta este 3 positivo
también queremos que se convierta en 3
negativo y este 3 positivo también 3
negativo ahora como tú puedes notar lo
que estamos haciendo es es algo es
voltear el signo cierto estamos
reflejando sobre y eso es equivalente a
cambiar el signo de la coordenada x
entonces esto esto es equivalente lo
escribo por acá es equivalente a
multiplicar menos 1 por la coordenada la
coordenada que voy a llamar x 1 esto es
esta es la coordenada x 1
al alargar al alargar esto en la
dirección y eso significa que queremos
que para cualquier altura que yo tome
quiero que sea el doble ahora eso es
alargarlo entonces esta coordenada en la
coordenada 32 no de hecho aquí no he
hecho el primer paso aún pero quiero que
quiero que se se quiero que tenga el
doble de altura entonces en lugar de
hacer 3,2 será 3.4 lo que estoy haciendo
es multiplicar por 12 a la coordenada
jet y en lugar de llamar a estos a las
entradas del vector x x1 y x2 voy a
ponerles el nombre de xy y entonces el
vector es igual a xy como coordenadas
esas son las coordenadas del vector
xy ahora no temas por tu vida porque
simplemente es notación aquí lo que
estoy haciendo es facilitar la
existencia de nosotros porque estamos
acostumbrados a ver un vector en su
forma x y en lugar de x 1 x 2 y xy
llevan a corresponder con los ejes de
coordenadas cierto entonces queremos
queremos construir una transformación
una transformación de algún vector x que
o mejor escribo de esta otra manera la
transformación de x y jane esto va a ser
igual a 1 - 1 x x entonces menos 1 por x
y ala y al hielo multiplicó por 2 2 así
que hacía así es como lo puedo escribir
en su lenguaje de transformación lineal
este sería el lenguaje de transformación
lineal pero pero cómo puedo construir
una matriz para esto lo que lo que vamos
a hacer es tomar
estamos en el re 2 entonces voy a tomar
la matriz identidad en el re 2 que sería
esta matriz 1 0 0 1 y le voy a aplicar
la transformación a cada columna de esta
matriz identidad entonces lo voy a hacer
que vamos a obtener tenemos tenemos una
ninguna nueva matriz es cierto tenemos
una nueva matriz
y esto será igual a la transformación
aplicada a cada columna entonces la
transformación de la primera columna que
sería la columna 1010 y después la
segunda transformación o la segunda
columna de esta nueva matriz sería la
transformación aplicada a la segunda
columna de la identidad que sería 01 y
ahí lo tenemos entonces a que es una
igual estas dos nuevas columnas la
transformación de la primera columna
sería ok vamos a hacerlo a pie tenemos a
es igual a la transformación de 10 eso
es x es 1 entonces lo multiplicamos por
menos 1 y tenemos menos 1 después 2 por
qué pero y es igual a 0 entonces tenemos
0 ahora el segundo término tenemos menos
x es 0 simplemente de 0 y 2 porque es
igual a 2 por 1
eso es igual a 2 tenemos entonces menos
1 002 ahora podemos decir que esta
transformación
algún vector xy entonces la
transformación de xy la podemos
describir como una matriz que multiplica
a un vector entonces esa es la matriz
menos uno menos 10 menos 10 y 0 2
multiplicando al vector x y ahora hay
que aplicarlo para verificar que si
funciona es cierto porque queremos ver
que en efecto lo refleja lo alarga así
que pongo primero este vector este punto
rosa es este vector cierto ese es el
punto entonces vamos a efectuar las
operaciones sobre este vector y lo que
voy a hacer es poner la matriz pongo la
matriz menos 1 002 que multiplica al
vector menos 32 entonces tenemos una
multiplicación de una matriz por un
vector así que hagamos esto menos 1 x
menos 3 estrés positivo +0 por 20
entonces nos queda un 3 positivo y
después 0 x menos 30
después más dos por dos es cuatro así
que nos queda
34 entonces lo que ya tenemos ese ahora
vamos con el siguiente punto que es 32
entonces ok
muy bien vamos con ese siguiente punto
32 pongo la matriz menos 10 y 0 2
multiplicando al vector 32 entonces
tenemos menos 1 por 3 es igual a menos 3
y después 0 por 20 entonces tenemos
menos 3 ahora 0 por 3 es igual a cero
más 2 por 2 es igual a 4 nos queda el
vector menos 34 y ese punto está
justamente justamente por aquí aquí está
menos 3 y 4
entonces ok aquí aquí estoy usando la
terminología se le puede decir
a esta transformación aplicada a cada
uno de estos vectores entonces tú puedes
decir hola a la transformación mapea
este punto a este punto o lo convierte o
lo transforma pero es simplemente tan
bueno estoy diciendo que ese punto es
transformado a este otro punto en r2
entonces ahora vamos con el siguiente
tenemos la matriz multiplicando al
siguiente vector que es el vector 3 - 2
entonces aquí menos 1 por 3 es igual a
menos 3 y 0 por menos 12 0 entonces nos
queda menos 3 ahora 0 por 13 0 más 2 por
menos 2 es igual a menos 4 tenemos
entonces el punto menos 3 menos 4
ese punto está más o menos por aquí
menos tres menos cuatro y sabemos que
sabemos que el conjunto de r2 que como
que conecta estos puntos bajo la misma
transformación se será mapeado al
conjunto r2 que conecta a estos puntos
en este otro lado cierto entonces así
que la imagen de este conjunto que
dibuje de este triángulo es simplemente
un conjunto de puntos que especifican a
este otro conjunto de vectores entonces
la imagen de este conjunto de vectores
no se específica a estos puntos este
este nuevo triángulo que tenemos bajo la
transformación de aquellos de aquel
conjunto de puntos entonces bueno
excelente hicimos o ha hecho esta
transformación lo que queríamos que
hiciera cierto lo reflejó primero y
después lo alargó entonces vemos que lo
alargó por un con un por un factor de
dos y lo volteó y de hecho en general
cualquiera de estas operaciones puede
ser una tránsfuga no puedes transformar
lo bueno es decir puedes regresar t o
regresar a la forma original entonces tú
puedes escribir la transformación en
esta forma y aplicarle esto a los
vectores base a las columnas de la
matriz identidad pero no
general es que cualquiera de estas
transformaciones que literalmente lo que
lo que hacen es alargar o reflejar o de
hecho hacernos pequeño lo que sea es la
está en la dirección del eje x o del eje
y serán o no serán matrices diagonales
entonces como puedes ver aquí también la
matriz a es una matriz diagonal estas
serán las transformaciones en las
matrices diagonales porque bueno
solamente tienen términos no nulos en la
diagonal cierto este es el caso 2 x 2 si
hago el caso 3 x 3 tendríamos ceros por
todas partes menos en la diagonal
principal ahí habrían números no nulos y
tiene mucho sentido porque este primer
término es esencialmente lo que estás
haciendo
al x 1 al término x 1
si tienes por ejemplo una matriz de 3 x
este tercer término es lo que les des a
la tercera dimensión a la cuarta
dimensión es el siguiente término
entonces tú puedes expander esta idea a
rn arbitrario cierto a cualquier
dimensión pero en fin de hecho lo que la
idea general de este vídeo era
introducirte a esta idea de crear de
diseñar transformaciones para cualquier
dimensión y creo que lo hemos logrado
bueno nos vemos